So, first, let's talk about performance. Usually, when we
say performance within processor speed. But even then, there
are really two aspects of performance that are not
necessarily identical. One is latency. It's about, how long does
it take from when we start something until it's
done. The other is throughput, which is, how many
things can we do per second. And one would
think through put is 1 over latency. So for example,
if it takes a half a second to do something,
then the number of those things we can do per second
is going to be 1 over one half and we get 2
for throughput but this is not always so. Think about a
car assembly line. We start with just a chassis. We then
move the car to where its engine is going to be installed.
We then move the car to where some wheels are going to
be added to it. We then have some doors installed and
some hood put together and so on. And now we
have a car. So the latency is from here to
here. Here's where we began the car, here's where we
have a final car. But we have an assembly line so
when the chassis moves here for the engine to be
installed. The next chassis gets put together. When we have installed
the engine, we move the car to the install wheels
station. Meanwhile the next car is getting its engine installed and
so on. So let's say that the latency
is 4 hours, but that it takes something like
20 steps for a car. If each of these steps takes the same amount of time and the
cars are just moving through these steps, then our
throughput is actually 5 cars per hour, not 0.25
cars per hour. So as you can see the
throughput and the latency may not be like this.